let us now run the datado pipeline on
the trivial info Circle
before we know that let us understand
how we have to prepare the data files
required to import in the pipeline we'll
refer to the buyer project as you can
see here normal interplay between skin
microbiota and plasma metabolite here we
have 36 SRA experiments you need to
click on the total number of SRE
experiments this will redirect you to
the total number of experiments and from
here we will extract the information of
the runs in the data set so you click on
file
format run info and click on create file
you also need to click on run selector
to download the metadata file for the
data set so you'll click on send to
again click on run selector and then go
searching for a good data set it's
important that your data should have
good characteristic values that could be
considered
for that you can open the Run selector
and scroll down to understand what type
of metadata is present in your data set
here we just have the information of the
type of samples we have one is the
control samples and the other one other
serious examples
in this study we have 36 samples in
total we'll be considering half of them
and run the pipeline
so here next we need to click on the
meta data table
now once we have both these files
downloaded let us see how we have to
extract specific characteristics from
the Run table that we get by clicking on
metadata
let's now open our Excel this thing you
need to check is the read length here
the read length is same for all the runs
now this relents the average re-length
you you can divide the read length by
two and consider the read length that
results for reverse and forward reads
let's say the read length is not the
same for all the runs that are present
in your data set in that case you can
take the minimum average of the values
and then divide it again by 2 and
consider the value obtained for reverse
read and forward grade length now here
to create your metadata file you need to
delete the columns with non-unique
values and just keep the ones with
unique values
here we just have one column with unique
values which tells us which samples are
controls and with samples are SUNY
assets patient samples
we just keep one specific column for
that and we delete the test
now here we have the patient number as
well with the seeds and the piece so let
us simply delete this and have a simple
term as control for all the control
samples
and psoriasis for all the psoriasis
samples
you have a lot of psoriasis samples and
lesser number of controls controls are
just 10. so let's consider just 10
psoriasis samples as well maybe
and we can delete the others
now say this fine
as a DOT txt file and name it as
metadata Dot dxt
okay
all right now it's very important to
check the formatting of the file before
you already upload it on the debug for
Server you need to make sure that there
is just one space between these two
columns
one spins separates the values into two
different columns so if you have more
than one space it will consider the next
base as another column
so I find specifics
spaces and replace it with a single
space
please make sure that you have no
additional row after the last row your
metadata file is now ready let's run the
pipeline
we'll go to 30 by an info server
if you already have an account on the
server great if you don't have you can
mail us at
marketing.com or support at the
ratepoint.bio so that we could create
demo credentials for you if you are new
on the server
the next thing that you need to do is
click on the amplicon 16 as 18s section
Unlimited genomics on the D by event for
server now we need to set certain
parameters at the preliminary step the
format of NGS data is fast queue for
databases we'll select all our data is
parent next we need to upload the Run
table file
in the CSV now we need to upload the
metadata file this is the very same
metadata file that we just prepared in
the dot txt format
now I click on submit now we are going
to run the pipeline
the first step is to click on start
to run the pipeline
click on OK this is a simple point and
click Pipeline and you have to set some
parameters
before you actually click on the button
here the read length if you remember was
500 the average treatment for all the
samples I'll divide it by 2 and I'll put
the parameter as 250 for both forward
and reverse lead length
QC filtering is a step that trim
sequences to a specified length it
removes sequences shorter than that
length and 12 hours based on the number
of ambigual spaces a minimum quality
score and the expected errors in a rate
next we'll click on replication count
replication count eliminates rates that
do not have a matched pair
next we click on pair merch
in the data do pipeline very much
performed by aligning the denoised
forward reads with a reverse complement
of the corresponding denoised Weaver
strings and then constructs the merged
contact sequences
next we'll click on cluster consensus
which constructs an amplicon sequence
variant table a high resolution version
of the otu table produced by traditional
methods next we click on remove kymers
where chimeric sequences are identified
to be removed next is a scientixon which
which will assign taxonomy to the
sequence radius
next we click on ape it is a package
written in R language for calculating
and visualizing the phylogeny based on
distance methods using the neighbor
joining algorithm
next is the phylocene algorithm
which is used to import store analyze
and graphically design complex
phylogenetic sequencing data that that
has already been clustered into
operational taxonomic units now here you
need to change some of the parameters
we'll change the ordination method to
pcoa with exonomical level you can do
either class or order and the pieces of
what taxi level you pick at the
taxonomical level you will get an
abundance plot we will also get a
dashboard where we can change these
structure levels and visualize our
microbial abundance in protocols
now what shall be put under color and
shape so referring back to your metadata
open the metadata file and put the
header here for the characteristic that
you had with specified which samples are
control samples and with samples are so
it has a sample so I'll just select
sample name it has to be in the same
format that's why I just copy and paste
it here sample underscore knee I'll save
it and then click on data visualization
which will help us produce various
interactive visualizations that we could
interact with and interpret biological
insights out of it understanding the
microbial abundance Alpha diversity beta
diversity now we'll give a name to our
pipeline
and save it
last week we click on run Pipeline on
cluster so these were the simple steps
on how you can run a pipeline on the
table info server we will wait for a few
minutes to some hours based on the type
of samples and the signs of samples that
we have picked to run the pipeline it
will take few minutes to few hours for
the pipeline to be processed once the
python is processed we will then
interpret the results